>> Sean: TONIGHT THE
PRESIDENT QUOTED THE DEMS WERE
TRYING TO DISTANCE THEMSELVES
BUT NOW, THAT MEANS THEY ARE
ENDORSING SOCIALISM, HATE OF
ISRAEL, AND THE USA.
NOT GOOD FOR DEMOCRATS.
ALSO BREAKING TONIGHT,
WHITE HOUSE COUNSELOR TO THE
PRESIDENT, KELLYANNE CONWAY,
DEFIED A CONGRESSIONAL SUBPOENA
WITH FULL SUPPORT OF THE
WHITE HOUSE.
LET ME READ FROM PAT CIPOLLONE,
THE WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL THAT HE
SENT TO CONGRESSMAN
ELIJAH CUMMINGS.
AND IN ACCORDANCE WITH
LONG-STANDING BIPARTISAN
PRESIDENT, MS. CONWAY CANNOT BE
COMPELLED TO TESTIFY BEFORE
CONGRESS WITH RESPECT TO MATTERS
RELATED TO OUR SERVICE AS A
SENIOR ADVISOR TO THE PRESIDENT,
THE FORM OF JUSTICE HAS ADVISED
ME THAT MS. CONWAY'S ABSOLUTELY
ABSOLUTE IMMUNE FROM
CONGRESSIONAL TESTIMONY WITH
RESPECT TO MATTERS RELATED TO OE
RESPECT TO MATTERS RELATED TO OR
SERVICE AS A SENIOR ADVISOR TO
THE PRESIDENT WHICH, BY THE WAY,
IS EXACTLY RIGHT.
KELLYANNE CONWAY JOYCE'S SOUND.
I DON'T THINK YOU LOOK TOO
WORRIED.
I'VE KNOWN YOU FOR MANY YEARS,
YOU'VE BEEN ON THE SHOW MANY
AREAS, YOU DON'T LOOK
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED.
>> I'M CONCERNED THAT THERE IS
SUCH A POLITICIZED NATION AND
WHAT THIS THING CALLED THE HATCH
ACT.
IF YOU GO BACK AND LOOK AT SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT ARE IN THE
ORIGINAL REPORT, THEY ARE JUST
RIPPED FROM THE HEADLINES.
THEY ARE NOT MY OPINION.
SO HERE'S AN EXAMPLE THAT THEY
PUT IN THEIR REPORT ORIGINALLY.
THEY HIT I SAID THAT THE
DEMOCRATIC FRONT RUNNERS ARE TOO
OLD, WHITE, MALE CAREER
POLITICIANS.
SO AT THE TIME, IT WAS JOE BIDEN
AND BERNIE SANDERS HER HEAD AND
THE BULLS.
I'M JUST READING THE NEWSPAPER
HERE.
NOW, FACT-CHECK, THEY ARE WHITE,
THEY ARE OLD, THEY ARE MALE, AND
THEY ARE CAREER POLITICIANS.
>> Sean: I'VE GOT TO TELL YOU
WHAT YOU'RE GUILTY OF.
YOU LIKE THE PRESIDENT.
YOU LIKE THE PRESIDENT, THIS IS
THE TREATMENT ANYBODY GETS.
>> I'M ALSO EFFECTIVE IN
INITIATING HIS POLICIES TO
AMERICANS.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR THE FLATTERY
THAT SOMEHOW THE TV APPEARANCE
BY ME IN THE SPRING OF 20 AGING
CAN SWING AN ELECTION IN 2020.
BUT, THEY ARE JUST MAD --
THEY KNOW THAT I HELP THE
PRESIDENT WHO GOT ELECTED ALL BY
HIMSELF BUT I'M STILL HERE
TALKING ABOUT HIS POLICIES.
THEY WOULDN'T LIKE ME TO HAVE
BEEN HAULED IN FRONT OF THE
OFFICE OF SPECIAL COUNSEL
MR. MUELLER BUT THEY COULDN'T DO
THAT BECAUSE I RAN A CAMPAIGN
THAT DIDN'T SPEAK TO RUSSIANS.
I DIDN'T TALK TO ANYBODY IN
MOSCOW.
TALK TO PEOPLE IN MICHIGAN AND
NORTH CAROLINA.
BUT, THIS IS A SERIOUS MATTER IN
THAT.
I WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY.
I HAVE NOTHING TO HIDE.
I'VE DID NOTHING WRONG.
BUT, THERE IS A LONG-STANDING
BIPARTISAN PRESIDENT AND IT
APPLIES TO ADMINISTRATIONS OF
BOTH PARTIES.
WHAT WOULD REALLY HAPPEN IF THE
HATCH ACT WERE APPLIED
RETROACTIVELY?
TO OTHER PEOPLE AND MEMBERS OF
THE ADMITS RATION CRUSHER MARK
HAVE YOU SEEN SOME OF THE THINGS
THEY'VE SAID AND DONE THAT HAVE
NEVER GOTTEN THIS KIND OF
TREATMENT?
I WOULD ALSO JUST TELL YOUR
VIEWERS TO LOOK AT THE LETTER
SENT BY WHITE HOUSE COUNCILMAN
ON JUNE 11, HIS ORIGINAL
RESPONSE, IT IS BRILLIANT.
EVERYONE SHOULD PULLED A LETTER
BECAUSE IN AND HE SAYS, AND THEN
US HAS NEVER BEEN CONTESTED BY
THE GUY WHO WENT UNDER, PROBABLY
BECAUSE I DID THE TESTIFYING,
HOW DIFFICULT IT ACTUALLY IS,
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE NOT
TELLING THE TRUTH THE ENTIRE
TIME.
MORE ABOUT THAT SOME OTHER TIME.
BUT WHAT PAT CIPOLLONE HE SAID
WAS, THIS SPECIAL COUNSEL, THE
OFFICE SPECIAL COUNSELOR HAS A
25 MILLION PLUS DOLLAR BUDGET
AND IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE AN
INDEPENDENT AGENCY.
HE FELT PRESSURE FROM MEMBERS OF
THE PRESS.
HE HAS CAPITULATED TO PEOPLE ON
CAPITOL HILL BECAUSE HE WANTS
THEM TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT KELLY
AND HERE THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
SILENCE HER.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO TAKE AWAY
MY FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
I'M IMMUNE FROM TESTIFYING.
SEE WHEN WOULD YOU MAKE FROM THE
PRESIDENT STREET, TRYING TO
DISTANCE HIMSELF FROM THE REAL
LEADERS OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AND FORCED TO EMBRACE THEM AND,
YOU KNOW, LOOK AT OMAR'S
COMMENTS ABOUT ISRAEL AND THE
U.S. AND ENDORSING SOCIALISM AND
THE GREEN NEW DEAL, ET CETERA.
>> ALL ABOUT THE BENJAMIN'S,
YES.
AND LYING TODAY IN THE PRESS
CONFERENCE, I MEAN, I'M ALWAYS
AMAZED ON THE FACT-CHECKERS,
JUST GO GAGA AND GENUFLECT WHEN
ANY ONE THAT IS FLAWED COME
APART FROM ME, THEY DON'T
FACT-CHECK THESE PEOPLE.
BUT LOOK, THE PRESIDENT IS RIGH
RIGHT.
PELOSI, GREG MEEKS, WE ARE ALL
RAINING DOWN ON THESE WOMEN
BEFORE ATTACKING THEM.
THEY ARE THE ONLY FOR DEMOCRATS
WHO GO AGAINST ANY HUMANITARIAN
AID CRISIS ON THE BOARD AGREED